Britain's decision on 5g has been
watched closely by its five eyes
partners and they don't all see it the
same way the u.s. and Australia have
already decided to exclude hawawa Canada
and New Zealand are yet to make their
decision British intelligence led by
GCHQ has concluded that the risks can be
managed and Boris Johnson has listened
to his spooks China is a serious
competitor a rival and it uses
intelligence methods to try to gain an
advantage but we've been dealing with
the challenge of having Huawei equipment
in our telecoms network for the last 15
years and the my successors in the
intelligence community are confident
that they can continue to manage this
risk you don't have to exclude it
entirely do you think others might look
at Britain's decision and follow suit I
think most European countries would like
to take a similar approach to Britain we
believe we've had the most rigorous
inspection arrangement of any country in
the world much more rigorous in America
the UK government has designated Huawei
as a high-risk vendor but manageable the
Americans aren't convinced and they
aren't happy there's gonna be this
debate over whether we have to pull out
of this Intelligence Sharing
relationship I worry also that the next
step could be you know in the debate
over a trade agreement we would make
this a precondition for going forward
and I'd hate to see our two countries at
loggerheads British security officials
have gambled that their decision won't
affect the important transatlantic
security relationship we'll have to see
Alistair bungle Sky News